[Music]
a streak of warm blood splattered across
the snow steam rose off it as it fizzled
into the ice crystals below the severed
leg had just spurted from lei twitching
only a few inches away torn clean off at
the hip like a broken barbie doll i
think it might have belonged to arthur
it wasn't the first time i'd seen limbs
cut off now i've got a few off myself in
my time
don't worry i'm not a serial killer just
a med student we all were i couldn't say
the same for the nightmare we
encountered up in the mountains that
terrible day the thin cold air was laden
with screams mine my friends and that
things all that had done to us all that
it was still doing to us and never once
did it stop shrieking and sobbing at the
top of its lungs like it wasn't even in
control of its actions it didn't want to
do this it just had to the violence was
as inevitable as the sunset i screamed
for kyle snow was coming down thick and
fast a curtain of burning brilliant
white i couldn't see anyone not even
that thing that was killing us the water
in my eyes was starting to freeze up it
was cold so damn cold what the hell was
going on here suddenly a dark shape was
moving towards me through the wall of
falling snow it was human vaguely moving
towards me with frantic speed i tensed
in anticipation when i then saw kyle
emerging from the fog he was splattered
with blood his face read from screaming
and exertion his eyes pleaded for help i
couldn't give him the horror caused my
body to react on autopilot with my eyes
climbing closed in terror all i could do
was open my mouth pointing with a
shaking frostbitten finger and force out
a scream behind you my words were
carried off by the brutal mountain winds
and with the sounds of mutilation ahead
of me all i could imagine with eyes
claimed clothes as i hit the frozen
ground was a long grey arm emerging from
the flurry behind kyle its gnarled
clawed fingers reaching for his head it
was meant to be the vacation of a
lifetime the kind of thing that you
could only experience once but you'd
never forget we all thought in our own
ways that we'd look back on the photos
with misty eyes when we were all old men
we didn't know that within a week of
arriving in switzerland whether any of
us would even make it to old age would
suddenly become an open question all
four of us were doctors in training even
if you don't know much about the
profession it probably won't surprise
you to hear that there's a lot of
practice and education involved before
you can ever really call yourself a
doctor without feeling like a fraud you
need to ace your sats then slog through
four years of pre-med another four years
of medical school then the better part
of a decade doing your residency seems a
little much i know but believe me you
don't want some cowboy sticking his
hands in your chest cavity without all
the proper training but after we finally
graduated from harvard med my friends
and i decided that we needed a break
before the profession swallowed us back
up again it was me brandon arthur and of
course kyle a lot of people i attended
class with would probably make a tidy
sum over the course of their medical
careers many of them would have made
fine doctors but all of us knew that
kyle molloy was more than that he was
going to be a truly great doctor he was
smart confident driven and had the kind
of smooth effortless charm that made you
just feel safe around him where he went
we followed so naturally when he
suggested we take a week-long sojourn in
switzerland the rest of us were all for
it we expected an easy week of gourmet
cheese fine chocolate and the occasional
jaunt down some old historic districts
the exact kind of relaxing break we
needed after the soul-crushing pressure
of eight years studying the hallowed art
of medicine but of course that wasn't
what kyle had planned for us it turned
out his tastes were far more extreme
than what the rest of us had in mind his
vision of a swiss vacation was mostly
forest hikes back country skiing
snowboarding and a little mountaineering
through the swiss alps apparently he'd
spent a good portion of his childhood
taking swiss vacations and wanted to
give us a little slice of his personal
paradise as someone who wasn't exactly
crazy about heights or the cold i can't
pretend i was eager at first but kyle
always found a way of talking us back
around it wasn't long until we were
booking our tickets then sitting on the
plane watching the mountains get bigger
through the window and our feet were on
swiss soil it was a beautiful country
and every bit as cold as i feared but
soon enough the cold would be the
absolute least of our worries as i
glanced over the breathtaking view of
the alps i had no idea of the terrible
nightmare lurking out there hidden in
the dark spaces of those great rocks
something i learned in med school is
that human beings are kind of like
fleshy time bombs their fuse ever
burning when you reach a certain age and
believe me that age is younger than you
think the assassin that will one day
sneak up from within and take your life
is already waiting inside you the
cluster of malformed cells that will one
day turn into an inoperable malignant
tumor the early whispers of the heart
defect that gives your ticker its
planned obsolescence the microscopic
ropes of defective genes that will one
day turn into alzheimer's or parkinson's
in some cases it's just a matter of
whether you can catch it in time but in
just as many cases there really is
nothing you can do you're just waiting
for it to get you after three days in
switzerland we're suiting up in our
thick coats and climbing boots having no
idea that the same principle applied to
us except this wasn't that nasty little
assassin within it was something outside
something that none of our skills or
knowledge could save us from something
very old and very dangerous we were in
fate's hands now and sometimes fate can
be cruel kyle was steaming ahead he
didn't just want us to ascend just any
mountain peak he wanted us to attempt
the due for spites the highest peak of
the monte rosa massive and the alps as a
whole kyle didn't think anything less
than that would be a challenge after all
this was our once in a lifetime vacation
before we fully started our residency
didn't we want to make this a truly
remarkable experience
and because it was kyle none of us
disagreed we started at the base of the
monterosa and began to rise its lowest
levels barely resembled its frosty peak
over 4 600 feet above we took pictures
of some of the wildlife the grazing
ebexes red deer and chamois arthur had
brought a pamphlet on the local wildlife
back at a tourist-friendly mountain
lodge and took great joy in pointing out
the different creatures to us as he saw
them brandon got a good laugh about the
fact that there was a small bird native
to the area known as the nut hatch kyle
forged ahead telling us tales of his
prior conquests the climb gradually
transitioned from calm to gruelling as
we ascended the mountain i could feel
the blisters forming on my feet as the
cold first made my face sting and then
go completely numb arthur still
consulting his pamphlet expressed
excitement to see a marmot when we
finally reached 2000 feet of elevation
brandon started to complain vocally
pouring himself a cup of coffee from his
thermos kyle chastised him for wimping
out already after all he said the
hardest parts were yet to come
oh if only he knew just how right he was
we ascended further feeling the air
thinning in our legs growing exhausted
beneath us i started to resend kyle as
he forged on despite it all how could he
keep going when the rest of us were
faltering it just wasn't fair when the
rest of us needed to take a breather we
could feel the sting of his silent
judgment he was always so damn perfect
we're almost there he kept saying even
though we all knew it wasn't true things
took a turn during one of our rest stops
we heard this strange noise a kind of
pain wailing or keening there was
nothing overtly menacing about it but
somehow just hearing that noise chilled
me deeper than any icy gust of mountain
breeze it's difficult to describe but
that terrible sobbing felt like the
purest distillation of true bottomless
despair i've never heard a more hopeless
and mournful noise referring to his
pamphlet again arthur speculated that
the noise could potentially be a lynx
such creatures were apparently native to
the area and their calls had a bizarrely
human quality to them but somehow deep
down i knew this thing wasn't human and
it wasn't an animal either whatever was
making those noises defied normal
metrics of categorization to the
surprise of no one me least of all kyle
decided to lead the way in the direction
of that awful noise brandon and arthur
followed him closely over the next
tundra getting closer and closer to the
sobbing i hung back a little further
gripped by the profound sense of dread i
didn't want to find out what was making
this noise i knew deep in my guts that
if ever we found out what was making
that noise something terrible would
happen and then moments later it did i
heard kyle gasp for the first time ever
the snow was blinding my view and i
couldn't make out what was actually
happening until arthur ran back toward
my direction and threw the blanket of
white snow and with a voice barely
audible through his trembling said that
there was a long grey creature he said
it was naked and looked kind of human
but definitely was not i could barely
make out what my buddies were doing
ahead of me but from the looks of it it
seemed like kyle was walking closer
every cell my body was screaming no no
no no no no but by that point it was
already far too late for all of us the
creature began to turn perhaps it was
raw animal instinct that saved me but i
began to turn too almost in unison to
look away from the creature i just knew
that whatever this thing was i couldn't
bear to see it and it was at that moment
as my body hit the snow and i forced my
eyes closed that the screaming began
first i could recognize the voices of
brandon arthur and kyle screaming and
then something worse i can only assume
it was the creature itself making the
most terrible racket shrieking moaning
sobbing and then
ripping and tearing blood spattering
across the snow i just cowered and shook
against the ground as a massacre
unfolded behind me i was listening to my
friends die powerless kyle all his
strength and direction stripped away by
terror was snatched by the creature as
freezing snowy wind gave it a cloak i
heard kyle's scream and then never heard
anything from him ever again
soon enough it was quiet once more no
noise saved for the howling wind and the
quiet sobbing of the abomination from
the snow i don't know for sure why the
creature spared me but part of me has
always suspected that it was because i
never looked at it i'll forever be
darkly curious as to what the monster
truly looked like but my friends found
out and now i'd never see them again i
wandered through the unforgiving cold
for hours fully expecting that my frozen
body would be found in the alps hours
days or even weeks later i didn't even
care anymore the cold numbed my skin my
limbs and my thoughts at some point a
helicopter descended onto the
mountainside full of men and tactical
gear with insignias i couldn't recognize
they wrapped me in an emergency blanket
and brought me in telling me i required
treatment it all turned ecstatic as we
fluttered away from the mountainside and
all i could think about was the monster
that had taken my friends from me it was
still out there waiting now go check out
scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy in
space the shy guy questions and theories
and scp-096 shy guy escape incident
096-1-8 containment breach for more on
the shy guy that haunts all of our
dreams